BRET?
>> Bret: TREY YINGST IN KABUL,
AFGHANISTAN.
TREY, THANK YOU.
LET'S BRING IN FORMER HAWAII
DEMOCRATIC CONGRESSWOMAN, FORMER
PRESIDENTIAL CANDIDATE AND ARMY
RESERVIST TULSI GABBARD JUST
BACK FROM DEPLOYMENT IN AFRICA
TO GO AFTER AL-QAEDA AFFILIATE
JIHADI U.SS THERE.
CONGRESSWOMAN, THANK YOU FOR
JOINING US.
>> HEY, BRET.
>> Bret: I WANT TO TALK ABOUT
AFGHANISTAN FOREIGN POLICY AND
COUNTER-TERRORISM.
I WANT TO START ON THE ISSUE OF
IMMIGRATION THAT'S PRESSING NOW
IN THE NEWS.
YOU TWEETED OUT THIS TODAY.
YOU SAID THE BIDEN-HARRIS OPEN
DOOR POLICY HAS BEEN A DISASTER.
IT NEEDS TO END NOW.
THE MAIN BENEFICIARIES OF OPEN
BORDERS GANGS, CARTELS AND HUMAN
TRAFFICKERS.
THE TRUMP POLICY OF HAVING
PEOPLE WAIT ON THE OTHER SIDE OF
THE BORDER WORKED AND NEEDS TO
BE REINSTATED.
YOUR THOUGHTS ABOUT WHAT'S
HAPPENING IN DEL RIO AND HOW THE
ADMINISTRATION IS HANDLING IT.
>> IT IS AN UTTER DISASTER AND
FAILURE AND IT DIRECTLY
ATTRIBUTED TO THE BIDEN-HARRIS
ADMINISTRATION'S OPEN-BORDER
POLICY.
THIS IS NOT ONLY A HUMANITARIAN
CRISIS.
IT IS A NATIONAL SECURITY CRISIS
AND IT'S SOMETHING I HAVE SAID
ALL ALONG, WHICH IS THAT IF WE
DO NOT SECURE OUR BORDERS, THEN
WE CAN'T HAVE A SECURE NATION.
THERE ARE SO MANY ISSUES THAT
HAVE HAPPENED UNDER THIS
ADMINISTRATION THAT HAVE LED TO
THIS POINT AND THEIR CONTINUED
FAILURE OF LEADERSHIP IS
EXACERBATING THE CRISIS THAT WE
ARE SEEING PLAY OUT BEFORE OUR
VERY EYES.
>> Bret: DO YOU THINK, HAVING
BEEN IN CONGRESS, THAT CONGRESS
CAN DEAL WITH THIS ISSUE?
>> CONGRESS HAS PROVEN,
UNFORTUNATELY, TO PUT PARTISAN
POLITICS AHEAD OF ACTUALLY
PASSING REAL NECESSARY
IMMIGRATION POLICY REFORM.
BUT WHAT WE HAVE SEEN UNDER THE
LAST SEVERAL MONTHS UNDER THIS
ADMINISTRATION, UNFORTUNATELY
AND JOE BIDEN IS A FRIEND, I
HOLD NO MALICE TOWARDS HIM.
BUT I HAVE TO SAY THAT THE
POLICIES AND DECISIONS THAT HAVE
BEEN MADE VIA EXECUTIVE ORDER BY
THE WHITE HOUSE HAVE LED TO THIS
OPEN BORDER POLICY WITH
THOUSANDS, TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
PEOPLE COMING AND ATTEMPTING TO
AND SOMETIMES SUCCESSFULLY
STREAMING ACROSS THE BORDER.
>> Bret: YOU THINK THAT'S A
NATIONAL SECURITY THREAT AS
WELL?
>> IT ABSOLUTELY IS.
HOW CAN YOU SAY THAT IT'S NOT
WHEN WE HAVE NO IDEA WHO IS
COMING ACROSS THE BORDER AND,
ONCE AGAIN, HOW CAN WE ENSURE
SAFETY AND SECURITY FOR THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE WHEN WE DON'T
HAVE A SECURE BORDER?
>> Bret: ALL RIGHT.
THE COUNTER-TERRORISM FIGHT.
THE PRESIDENT TALKING ABOUT HOW
IT'S EVOLVING, HOW IT'S GOING TO
CHANGE.
TAKE A LISTEN.
>> WE WILL MEET TERRORIST
THREATS THAT ARISE TODAY AND THE
FUTURE IN A FULL RANGE OF TOOLS
AVAILABLE TO US.
WE ARE BETTER EQUIPPED TO DETECT
AND PREVENT TERRORIST THREATS
AND WE ARE MORE RESILIENT IN OUR
ABILITY TO REPEL THEM AND TO
RESPOND.
>> Bret: A LOT OF PEOPLE,
CONGRESSWOMAN, WHO SAY WHAT
HAPPENED IN AFGHANISTAN, WHAT IS
HAPPENING NOW, AND HOW WE
HANDLED IT HAS REALLY OPENED THE
DOOR FOR MORE TERRORISTS.
YOU HAVE JUST COME BACK FROM
AFRICA WHICH IS ALSO A HOT BED
OF RADICAL JIHADISTS.
YOUR THOUGHTS ON WHERE WE ARE.
>> WELL, AS YOU KNOW, BRET, IN
BOTH EAST AND WEST AFRICA, THERE
IS A SURGE OF THESE JIHADISTS
TERRORISTS AL-QAEDA, ISIS AND
AFFILIATED GROUPS ARE INCREASING
IN THEIR STRENGTH.
THE WITHDRAWAL FROM AFGHANISTAN
IS SOMETHING THAT I AGREED WITH
YOU ABOUT, UNFORTUNATELY, THE
WAY THAT THIS ADMINISTRATION
EXECUTED THAT WITHDRAWAL HAS
BEEN AN UTTER AND ABJECT
DISASTER WHICH IS CONTINUING TO
PLAY OUT AS WE SPEAK.
FOR THOSE WHO SAY AND WE SHOULD
CONTINUE TO MONITOR AFGHANISTAN
TO MAKE SURE THAT THERE ARE NO
AL-QAEDA AND ISIS STRONGHOLDS
THAT ARE ALLOWED TO START TO
TAKE ROOT.
IF WE ARE SEEING THAT THAT IS
STARTING TO HAPPEN, THEN WE NEED
TO GO AND TAKE THEM OUT.
BUT WE SHOULD NOT BE UNDER THE
ALLUSION THAT THIS IS A PROBLEM
THAT'S ONLY LIMITED TO
AFGHANISTAN AND THE PROOF OF
THAT IS THAT AL-QAEDA FOR A VERY
LONG TIME HAS BEEN ABLE TO GET
REFUGE AND ACTUALLY HAVE
TRAINING CAMPS AND SUPPORT IN
PAKISTAN, WHICH IS A PROBLEM
THAT NOT HASN'T BEEN ADDRESSED
BUT WE HAVE SEEN THE UNITED
STATES CONTINUE TO SUPPORT
PAKISTAN IN SPITE OF THIS KNOWN
FACT AND RELATE.
SO THIS IS A BIGGER ISSUE HERE
THAT REALLY NEEDS TO BE
ADDRESSED.
ADDRESS
>> Bret: ARE YOU STILL A
DEMOCRAT.
>> YES.
>> AND CONTINUE TO BE DESPITE
THE CRITICISM ON A NUMBER OF
FRONTS.
>> LOOK, I HAVE NEVER BEEN ABOUT
PARTY POLITICS, BRET.
I THINK YOU KNOW THAT ABOUT ME.
I'M ABOUT PUTTING COUNTRY FIRST.
THE PROBLEMS THAT WE ARE SEEING
ON A WHOLE HOST OF POLICY FRONTS
IS THOSE IN POSITIONS OF POWER
AND LEADERSHIP, PUTTING PARTISAN
POLITICS, THEIR OWN SELFISH
DESIRE FOR POWER AHEAD OF THE
INTERESTS OF THE COUNTRY.
AHEAD THE PEOPLE OF THE PEOPLE.
AND THAT'S WHAT I ALWAYS TRY TO
DO MY VERY BEST IN LOOKING AT
DIFFERENT POLICIES IS WE HAVE TO
PUT THE PEOPLE AND THE INTERESTS
OF OUR COUNTRY FIRST.
>> Bret: WELL, I WANT TO ASK YOU
ABOUT THIS.
WE ARE JUST GETTING THE TIP OF
THE ICEBERG ABOUT THIS JOHN
DURHAM INVESTIGATION AND THERE'S
BEEN AN INDICTMENT OF A HILLARY
CLINTON CLINTON ATTORNEY,
MR. SUSSMANN, ABOUT BASICALLY
INFUSING THIS RUSSIA NARRATIVE
WITH THE HELP OF VARIOUS MEDIA
OUTLETS AND OTHERS.
AND IT MAY GO OVER PLACES.
WE DON'T KNOW.
WE ARE FOLLOW IT BUT YOU HAVE A
UNIQUE PERSPECTIVE IN THAT
HILLARY CLINTON ONCE CALLED YOU
A RUSSIAN ASSET.
JUST TO REMIND PEOPLE.
TAKE A LISTEN.
>> THERE ARE GOODS GOING TO DO
THIRD PARTY.
I'M NOT MAKING ANY PREDICTIONS.
BUT I THINK THEY HAVE GOT THEIR
EYE ON SOMEBODY WHO IS CURRENTLY
IN THE DEMOCRATIC PRIMARY.
AND THEY ARE GROOMING HER TO BE
THE THIRD PARTY CANDIDATE.
SHE IS A FAVORITE OF THE
RUSSIANS.
YEAH, SHE IS A RUSSIAN ASSET YOU
I MEAN TOTALLY.
THEY KNOW THEY CAN'T WIN WITHOUT
A THIRD PARTY CANDIDATE.
>> Bret: THEY WENT ON TO CONFIRM
THAT THAT WAS YOU THAT SHE WAS
REFERRING TO.
YOUR THOUGHTS AS WE ARE STARTING
TO GET THIS DURHAM INVESTIGATION
AND WHAT THAT MEANS.
>> CONFIRMS WHAT I HAVE KNOWN TO
BE TRUE, WHICH IS THAT YOU HAVE
THE POWER ELITE, PEOPLE LIKE
HILLARY CLINTON, THOSE AROUND
HER WORKING WITH THE MEDIA, THE
DEEP STATE IN ORDER TO BRING
DOWN THE DESTRUCTION AND
DOWNFALL OF ANYONE THAT THEY
DEEM TO BE A THREAT TO THEIR
POWER.
OUTSIDERS, PEOPLE LIKE ME,
PEOPLE LIKE DONALD TRUMP, IT
DOESN'T MATTER, DEMOCRAT OR
REPUBLICAN, IF THEY IDENTIFY,
HEY, THIS IS SOMEONE WHO IS NOT
GOING TO TOE THE LINE.
THIS IS NOT SOMEONE WHO IS NOT
GOING TO FOLLOW KIND OF THE
ESTABLISHMENT WAY OF THINGS THAT
ARE ACCEPTED, THEY POSE A
THREAT.
AND WE WILL DO -- THEY WILL DO
ALL THEY CAN TO SILENCE OR
SENSOR OR CANCER WHAT THEY VIEW
TO BE A THREAT.
SO THIS IS BIGGER THAN ABOUT ME
OR TRUMP OR ANYONE ELSE.
THIS IS ACTUALLY A THREAT TO OUR
COUNTRY AND OUR DEMOCRACY.
AND THE ARROGANCE THAT THESE
PEOPLE HAVE IN THINKING THEY
HAVE THE RIGHT TO MANIPULATE THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE WHAT THEY VIEW,
WHAT THEY HEAR, WHAT THEY SEE
ALL TO PRESERVE THEIR OWN
SELFISH INTERESTS, NOT CARING AT
ALL ABOUT THE IMPACT ON THE
COUNTRY, THE IMPACT OF THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE OR WHO GETS HURT
ALONG THE WAY.